hey guys i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen today's edition of what i
in a day youtuber reviews
is sponsored by squarespace and i will
be taking a look at
makeup shayla and at your request i have
been
actively trying to cut these videos down
while still giving lots of context so
please let me know if this video was too
long not enough information
or just write in the comments below now
if you're not familiar with squarespace
it's an all-in-one platform to run your
business whether you're looking to build
a website
blog online store or use their marketing
tools and analytics
as a blogger myself i love that
squarespace has a number of
seo tools to take the guesswork out of
making your site google friendly
and it also has appointment scheduling
tools for online booking
or coordinating calendars i also
obviously do a lot of social media
so my bloggers will really find the
social sharing buttons helpful
while also setting up email campaigns
for mailing lists
when everything in your digital presence
works together like this
it makes it so much easier for you to
focus on your actual business
you can check out squarespace.com for a
free trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
abby sharp to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain
okay so let's talk shayla shayla is a
popular figure here on youtube
making videos pertaining to all things
makeup
fitness and health many of her videos
surrounding
fitness are centered around her weight
loss and fitness journey
documenting updates in her fitness goals
as well as what she
eats in a day so shayla recently
transitioned off of a keto diet due to
it
not really fitting her lifestyle which i
totally can understand
and has instead turned to what she calls
a balanced way of eating
now before we jump into my review i want
to start with my general disclaimer that
the information in this video is for
entertainment and educational purposes
only
and you should always seek out the help
of a registered dietitian or medical
professional for your
unique needs also don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
and ring the bell so that you never miss
out on a video
finally i want to flag that there is a
lot of food weighing going on in this
video
which can be triggering for some of my
viewers so feel free to just skip those
scenes
if this does not feel supportive to you
also
while we do watch an entire work day's
worth of content
we cannot catch a youtuber's entire
catalog
so please keep in mind that what you see
may not fully reflect a full creator's
diet
i also shot this video a few months ago
to get ahead for baby
but we'll be providing a few last minute
insights on her new
results video where relevant okay so in
her video entitled fitness update and
full day of eating
shayla discusses that she counts her
macros and calories meticulously
weighing and measuring her food so that
she sticks to a very specific
1885 calories per day she herself
describes this process as
exhausting and hopes that once she gets
to the maintenance phase
she can stop tracking now you know my
general concern around strict
macro and calorie counting is that these
external messages
often override our hunger and fullness
cues
and this can create a lot of body
distrust
it's also like she says mentally
exhausting
and i would think a lot of that mental
load could be
alleviated by not stressing so much over
eating
10 versus 20 grams of strawberries i
also want to flag that calorie counting
is
a really imperfect science you know food
manufacturers can be 20
off of the calories that they list which
can easily put a tracker
over or under their specific caloric
goal
plus our body's natural needs will ebb
and flow depending on the day
and none of that is accounted for with
strict calorie counting
but alas if shayla feels that this helps
her identify how certain foods
or portions make her body feel and fuel
her
and if it's not triggering for her then
i mean
fine you know i'm not venomously against
having a general knowledge of the
calories in foods
as a tool but considering that she
herself
calls this out as exhausting i'm not
really sure
how valuable a tool it really is anyways
let's look at her first meal on day one
so it's really important for me that i
just stay consistent which means for me
eating the same thing every day and it
doesn't bother me
um so the first meal of the day for me
after i work out and i don't eat before
my workout i just have a pre-workout
so as soon as i'm done working out take
my shower and then i make my oatmeal
i've been loving unsweetened coconut
milk because it has low
calories low carbs low everything i just
got
creamy peanut butter what else do i add
i'll do blueberries
strawberries banana it
is so good and it's filling i think
before
i used to only eat two meals a day okay
so shayla
like a lot of fitness personalities does
mention that she eats the same thing
pretty much every day
and she says that apparently it doesn't
bother her
now i get the purpose of this is to
really take the guesswork out of
counting
every calorie in new meals which is
exhausting enough
but variety is the spice of
life even if you're eating all really
healthy foods
it's really hard to get every single
micronutrient
antioxidant and fatty acid when you eat
the same handful of foods
in my opinion the healthiest diet is not
a perfect
diet it's a varied diet also
i just have to flag that i know i just
said that having knowledge of the
calories and food was
a potential tool for certain populations
but wow that was triggering even for me
hence why i mean i'm not going to show
much of that weigh-in clip
now while i'm not suggesting at all that
this is disordered behavior for shayla
this can be triggering to watch for a
lot of my viewers
because carefully weighing out food
is one of the hallmark behaviors for
those struggling with disordered eating
again this might not be problematic at
all for shayla it sounds like this is
just what she does
but i'm just flagging that it's not
something that i recommend for the
general population
for this reason all that said i mean
this breakfast
does look pretty well balanced we've got
carbs and fiber from the oatmeal and
fruit
we've got healthy fats from the pecans
coconut flakes and peanut butter
and a little bit of protein from the
nuts and
nut butter as well i would say though
that because this is a post-workout meal
especially a workout that she did fasted
we may want to actually up the protein a
bit i know i know a lot of you
think that i am always worried about
protein it's like the running joke here
but for optimal training recovery we
would probably want to see around
20 to 30 grams post-workout for the
average person
so some ideas would be to switch to a
higher plant-based milk like soy
she could use powdered peanut butter
instead of regular for some extra
protein in there
or maybe adding some whipped egg whites
or blended tofu
into the oats also while i love
the healthy fats going on in this
breakfast fat is not as
important after workout as protein and
carbs
as it may slow down the absorption of
the protein and carbs
which are needed to replenish muscle
stores and help with recovery
if we wanted to optimize the
post-workout nutrition
i would probably up the healthy fats in
some of her other meals
and increase the protein a little bit in
this one let's see what she has to say
next a lot of you guys have been asking
me if i'm still intermittent fasting i'm
still
fasting i only fast like four to five
days
a week and i don't really track it so i
eat my last meal around
five and then my first meal of the day
ends up being around 10 30 so it's
i think that's like 18 hour it's a fast
19 hour fast
um so that's just monday through friday
and it's just gotten to the point where
it's just part of my routine i don't
even have to think about it anymore um
not like when i first started i was
thinking
i was like i got one more heart i could
eat not anymore it's just
it's become kind of natural for me okay
so
let's quickly talk intermittent fasting
because there is some research to
suggest that intermittent fasting
can be effective for weight loss but
that really shouldn't be
all that surprising i mean when you
restrict yourself to an 8 or 10
hour eating window you'll likely just
eat less
in fact while there may be some
additional benefits for
insulin resistance in patients with
pre-diabetes a review of the literature
did not find that intermittent fasting
was any better for weight loss than
continuous caloric restriction there is
a lot to unpack on intermittent fasting
i'm going to be honest
so let me know in the comments if you
want to see a whole video
specific to that what i do want to flag
is that i get that this way of eating
comes naturally
and easy to some people but for others
and i've seen it often there is a risk
that these restrictive hours
make you so ravenous that you can't help
but overdo it when you finally
do eat now in shayla's case
the combination of weighing every piece
of food
meticulously tracking macros and
calories and practicing intermittent
fasting
suggests there are a lot of hardcore
diet behaviors
going on every single day i mean
it must be completely consuming
so i do worry how shayla could be able
to sustain this in the long run
and what would happen to her body and
mind when she eventually transitioned
off of this way of eating
anyways let's look at lunch
so for lunch i'll eat scrambled eggs
white rice i'll scramble eggs with
spinach i'll add add my ground
chicken in there just for protein three
eggs
and cauliflower tortillas is that all
that i eat
it seems like it's not a lot but but it
is so my lunch is the biggest
meal of the day and it keeps me full
for hours typically it's between 700
and 900 calories just depending on like
how hungry i am sometimes i'll get my
oatmeal and i'm like oh
i'm still hungry and then i'll make my
lunch bigger than
usual okay so these look pretty good i
mean
i totally love me some good tacos
but while i'm not surprised that these
keep her full for a really long time
there is a lot of protein in one meal i
mean
we got three eggs and ground chicken and
the cheese
all of which adds up to just over 72
grams of protein
some of which we probably could have
used up in that breakfast
so research does suggest that around 1
gram per pound
or 2.2 grams per kilogram per day
is likely the most that our muscles and
body can effectively make use of
for muscle and tissue synthesis so for
somebody weighing 150 pounds who
consumed all of their calories in three
meals
each meal would need to have about 50
grams of protein
however it would be even more beneficial
to break this up
further and add in some snacks since
another study found that the
optimal dose for protein per meal for
muscle growth and maintenance
is about 0.18 grams per pound of body
weight
or 0.4 grams per kilogram so if we again
are looking at 150 pound person
the maximum amount of protein that can
likely be used for
muscle synthesis and repair at a time
is around 27 grams of protein after this
threshold is passed
the nutrients would not likely be used
for muscle protein synthesis
and would instead be diverted towards
oxidation for energy or storage
so my suggestion would be to just spread
the protein out
throughout the day i mean you can pop
those eggs up into breakfast
keep the ground chicken and cheese at
lunch and if she's more hungry at this
meal which is totally legit
we could up the fiber-rich carbs or fat
to compensate
i would also love to just see a little
more veggies going on
as no cauliflower tortillas don't count
i mean i like those things personally
and i love that cauliflower is the first
ingredient in them
but as an example one serving contains
only six percent of your daily vitamin c
compared to 92 percent in actual whole
cauliflower
so it's just not the same so in her
updated results video she mentioned
she's now having less chicken
and more veggies as a salad so yay i'm
so
glad to hear that it seems like she's
gathered that data for herself
and is just kind of tweaking things to
make her diet work better for her
also i will say i love and appreciate
the fact that
shayla identifies that some days she'll
eat
a little bit more depending on how
hungry she is allowing for
at least a little bit of flexibility in
a diet like this
which is so important so yeah i was
really happy to hear that
let's take a look at dinner moving on
to dinner which is usually at around 4
30 5 o'clock
5 30 in that window this is just like
okay what what do i have left
to eat so typically i'll do ground
chicken which i love oh
i just love ground chicken i'll put some
spinach in there
cheese and i've been loving the air
fried
potatoes they're so crispy they taste so
good they cook in like 11 minutes
so i'll just put a little olive oil in
there cook them in the airfryer
shake them up a little bit add some salt
and put the cheese on it oh
i get so excited to make that every
night okay yum
i mean mine is like putting the plastic
in the microwave which
i do try not to do habitually as there
is concern in the literature that a lot
of plasticizers and additives in
plastics
like bpa and phthalates can cause
hormonal disruptions
one analysis of 455 common plastic
products
including some supposedly bpa-free ones
found that 95 of them tested positive
for estrogenic activity when microwaved
or heated
the issue is that most of the research
we have on this
is done on animals so while the results
seem super scary we don't know
for sure how these impact human children
and adults especially in moderation
but if you want to be extra cautious i
would suggest just reheating things
in glass or ceramic and placing a paper
towel or
a ceramic plate on top this also
warrants a whole other video so if you
are interested
leave me a comment below and i will
leave some links to a very comprehensive
two-part series
on endocrine disruptors and plastic from
my blog
as for the food itself we've got some
more ground chicken
some air fried potatoes with cheese and
a little spinach
again this meal is on the higher protein
side at just over
55 grams but since she isn't having any
snacks
it does make sense that she's kind of
trying to fit most for protein
into those last two meals i'm also happy
to see that she's using
oil what i call smartly meaning not
completely being afraid of it
but also just adding enough to get her
veggies nice and crisp
and while i love the bed of spinach
going on i think we could definitely
up the produce in her day in fact
between
all three meals i calculated the amount
of fruit and veg that she got
and we're looking at less than one
serving of fruit
and a half of a serving of vegetables
that is just
not enough and since we're also not
seeing any variety in the produce
since she eats the same thing every day
we're not going to
maximize on nutrients antioxidants or
fibers either
this would be a really easy fix in my
books without really impacting her
macros or calories that much
so she could easily throw in some
sauteed peppers some mushrooms
carrots squash broccoli tomatoes
cauliflower
you name it to up the nutrition in her
day in her updated results video she
says she's now having asparagus which is
a really great change
and that plus the salad at lunch will up
the produce by about one to two servings
so that's amazing
also for those of you wondering how
worrying about specific
amounts of protein in one meal versus
the other or specific servings of fruits
and vegetables is compatible with
intuitive eating
i'm just giving you kind of numbers
based on sports nutrition
research for nutrition optimization
but in real life it would really be as
simple as just thinking about a balanced
plate where you're filling half of that
plate with vegetables
a quarter with your carbs and a quarter
with your protein
and we're looking for an overall pattern
here i mean
i am in no way saying that every meal or
even every day needs to be
perfect i am using these videos as a way
to show you and give you some ideas on
how you can make these meals a little
bit more balanced
but i am in no way suggesting that every
single day or every single meal
needs to be perfectly planned and let's
be real
thinking about like a balanced plate is
a heck of a lot easier
than meticulously counting and weighing
every calorie and macro
anyway let's hop over to day two
in this pale open i log everything
because you know i'm tracking my macros
all right i want it to like drizzle
you know over but i don't think that's
gonna work i'm gonna put it right in the
center i'm just gonna lick the rest of
this listen you gotta eat everything
okay
so boom there you have it 646
calories okay so
same same as day one with a side of
myfitnesspal
next let's take a look at lunch
this meal is pretty easy i just need the
ground turkey
mild cheddar cheese my siete
almond flour tortilla so freaking bomb
and spinach so this is pretty easy i
just make the tortilla
add the cheese and then add oh look at
that
spinach and ground turkey or you can do
ground chicken or ground
beef just like a super lean healthy taco
and boom okay so this kind of looks like
a scaled down version of day one's lunch
so we have a little bit more of a
balanced amount of protein here with
you know the carbohydrates and the fat
but i would still say not enough
veg i would love to see a side salad
or some sauteed bell peppers and onions
like fajita style
or even some steamed frozen vegetables
to make this
really super simple this alone would
help her
boost up her fiber which would help keep
her situated
given her limited caloric budget okay
let's move on to dinner
up in here i'm going to add lentils
that i meal prepped
you guys can see it right here and then
i'm going to add spinach
ground chicken and cheese
guys let's see what it looks like here
so i'm going to put this in the
microwave and then when it comes out i'm
gonna add avocado
yum i mean this dinner looks great i i
love a good protein bowl or
chicken bowl bowl whatever you want to
call it um
i like that we have some starch in the
rice we got protein in the lentils and
chicken
we've got some fat from the cheese and
the avocado
and albeit while it's not really
sufficient
we do have some veggies with the quarter
cup of spinach
honestly to me that's like more of a
garnish so
again i would love to see that beefed up
and not necessarily just with spinach
either i mean
i get that it's super easy because it's
already triple washed and it's in a
package ready to go
and we all think of spinach as a
superfood
but like i said we would ideally want to
see her
switch that up so spinach for example
may contain vitamin a c iron and calcium
which is great but it's lacking in
lycopene which is found in tomatoes
anthocyanins found in purple cabbage
and vitamin d for example which can be
found in mushrooms
so there's no such thing as a superfood
that can do it all and that is why
we want to see variety and speaking of
variety
i have seen that shayla relies heavily
on ground poultry for her meals
which is a lean protein rich choice so
i get why it's so popular with the
fitness crowd but i'm really happy to
see her kind of stretch
her animal protein with some lentils
which
not only would help boost the fiber but
as we know eating more plant-based can
help to reduce
our risk of heart disease stroke
diabetes and maybe even some cancers
let's take a look at day three and on
this day
shayla said that she was only eating two
meals per day
since it would save time and she would
rather
eat twice and be productive the rest of
the day
i mean i guess so there's
no denying that cooking and eating does
take
time out of your day but i'm just so
disappointed that we've gone to a place
in society where eating is such a low
priority
that we could practically forego it in
the name of productivity
these days not even taking into
consideration
covet life 20 of americans order food
from an app
with 56 of the population reporting to
eat out
or order takeout two to three times a
week
in addition to this only 80 percent eat
their lunch at their desk
and over half of young adults report
eating on the run
or being too busy to choose healthful
foods why are we not prioritizing
something that not only gives us fuel
and energy to perform but also gives us
pleasure and enjoyment in life i'm not
saying you need to quit your day job to
become a martha stewart
and make your own puff pastry churn your
own butter and feed your sourdough
starter like a baby twice a day if that
does not bring you
joy but making time to eat a meal
uninterrupted is integral to helping you
tune into your hunger
and fullness cues without distraction
and
to just building a more pleasurable and
balanced relationship with food
i get that calorie counting also kind of
interferes with these cues
but i still do think that you're not
more productive
without a proper break in fact
research has shown that taking breaks
throughout the day can actually
increase productivity through allowing
for an increase in focus
improving mental well-being increasing
creativity
and allowing time to take part in
healthful habits
having said all of that if cooking is
not your jam
and trust me i get that some of us are
just
too busy with life and trying to support
a family to put
an hour in every night to make dinner
then i
do recommend meal prepping like shayla
does
this ensures that you have all the
building blocks of a healthy meal
so you can easily throw them together on
the fly with very little thought
hopefully leaving more room to sit down
savor
and enjoy let's take a look at her first
meal of the day
boom there you have it oh that looks
good
why are you looking at my food like that
okay so this is
essentially the exact same meal as we
saw for lunch on the first day
but with a little bit of rice in there
and even more protein in fact
this has like 80 grams of protein now
i understand of course she is trying to
fit all of her nutritional needs into
just
two meals but as we discussed before
this is probably not the best way for
her to see optimal
muscle growth which she does mention is
of course a goal of hers
also no judgment i mean if you're not a
food lover i get it
but i'm not sure how long i could go
living on just ground chicken
cheese spinach eggs and tortillas
now she also briefly talks about her
supplement regime so
let's take a look at that i love taking
these vitamins so probiotics
which give you i guess good bacteria
[Applause]
a multivitamin women's multivitamin
and these are so good digestive pills
so you take these after you eat and they
just help digest your food um
obviously consult a doctor because i'm
not a doctor okay this is just what i
take
and what i like and what i guess just
works for me okay
so the first supplement that shayla
takes is probiotics which
i think can be helpful for a lot of
people probiotics help to increase the
beneficial bacteria in our guts
which research suggests may play a role
in everything from
digestion immunity heart health
allergies
weight management and mental health now
the connection between
probiotics and weight management may be
of particular interest to shayla
since certain probiotics particularly
those that contain lactobacillus
have been linked to a lowering the
absorption of dietary fat
b increasing glucagon-like peptide
1 aka glp-1 which is a
gut hormone known to improve metabolic
function
and c increasing angiopotent
like four aka ang ptl4 which
is a protein that plays a central role
in controlling fat stores
all of this is early research but i do
think we're just
scratching the surface when it comes to
fully understanding
probiotics and body weight never mind
the interaction between probiotics and
general health
now she also takes a multivitamin which
is something that she may actually
benefit from since
she doesn't seem to eat a whole lot of
fruits and veg
i don't believe that everyone needs a
multivitamin but if you're restricting
calories and therefore food
and your diet is severely limited like i
would say shayla's is
a multivitamin may help you fill in
those gaps
lastly she talks about taking an enzyme
supplement to help with her digestion
and this is where we hit a bit of a snag
so enzyme supplements are supposed to
help us with our digestion
since they are a source of the digestive
enzymes
that our bodies just naturally produce
in order to break down and digest foods
that we're eating
however unless there is a specific
health concern
at play which limits the amount of these
enzymes that we can produce
and or release there really is a limited
role for these supplements in the
average
healthy diet i spoke about this when i
talked to my colleague andrea hardy in
this video on bloating
but aside from vino and lactaid there is
little evidence to support combination
digestive enzymes
like these and you might think well
it can't hurt but i looked up these
particular pills
and found them on sale for a hundred and
four
dollars um yeah
that hurts of course as i've mentioned
before
there are specific situations where
enzymatic replacement
may be indicated such as in the event of
pancreatic insufficiency
cystic fibrosis certain types of cancer
such as pancreatic
colorectal and stomach cancers or after
gastric or pancreatic surgery
so if none of these ring a bell for your
recent medical history
you probably don't need to be
supplementing with pricey combination
enzyme replacement pills also if shayla
is finding her meals are difficult to
digest
this is why i would actually recommend
having smaller
more regular meals throughout the day
rather than just two
or even just three larger meals
now let's take a look at dinner and i'm
hoping it's not
another repeat
so boom here we have it oh i can't wait
to eat this so on a scale of
one to hungry right now i'm kind of just
at like a three
i ate my first meal today so late that
i'm not really that hungry
um but i need to stop eating so i can
start my fast
so there you have it okay so this is one
of the reasons why i don't always love
the intermittent fasting thing because
like she said she's not even hungry but
she has to eat right now because she has
to
finish eating before a specific time on
the clock
i can't imagine it feels really good to
be eating a
huge meal like this when you really have
no appetite
at all as for the meal i mean here we go
again we've got
rice chicken tiny bit of spinach on a
couple of tortillas
honestly it's not really surprising to
me that shayla doesn't
want to make time to eat i would
probably lack enthusiasm about the meals
too if it was always the same same
anyways after dinner she talks a little
bit more about her choice to fast which
for her is a solid 16 to 18 hours a day
so let's take a look at what she has to
say about it
i eat at 10 10 30 that's like normal for
me
but fasting will make
you snatched mark my words it will
you're gonna wake up in the morning
okay and you will be snatched you will
be all the way flat
um and i feel like that's one one of the
ways
to get abs is to fast which means it
doesn't mean you're starving yourself it
means that you're eating
all of your macros all of your calories
everything
in a shorter window and it works
period uh yeah
so shayla suggests that she's using
intermittent fasting
as the key to looking snatched and
waking up flat
in an effort to get abs now first of all
while we've already established that
intermittent fasting may help some
people lose weight
getting a flat stomach is not
necessarily
going to be the result of this now for
one
women naturally store more fat than men
do making it evolutionarily harder
to attain a six pack one hormone
estrogen has been linked to this
increase in fat storage in areas like
the thighs
butt and lower abdomen as a protective
and
evolutionary mechanism for childbearing
now another thing that i want to flag is
that shayla talks a lot about spot
reduction here so
wanting to have leaner arms or a flatter
stomach etc
but research suggests that this is very
unlikely
especially for women one study for
example had individuals train their abs
for six weeks
and while endurance and strength did
increase
there was no significant decreases in
abdominal
fat similarly another study had a group
trained their non-dominant leg for 12
weeks
and found that while the training was
effective at reducing overall
fat mass the reduction was not achieved
uniquely in that leg i also want to say
that it is
totally fine to have fitness goals it's
even fine for some of those goals
to be grounded in aesthetics i mean it's
hard
not to play into these pressures
especially in the fitness community so i
am not judging shayla
for just trying to survive in diet
culture
and do what she's been taught but i
would just have
loved to hear about some of the
non-aesthetic benefits of intermittent
fasting to her whether
that's because she's feeling more
energized or more satisfied
or her thinking is more clear etc
because if it doesn't feel good
i just don't know how sustainable it
really is
also if shayla finds that fasting helps
her to feel better i mean
that is great but it's not necessarily
safe or healthy for
everyone especially for women doing
these 16 to 18 hour fasts
research suggests that when women's
calories get too low from frequent fast
or extended fasts they may see a
disruption in luteinizing hormone
and follicle stimulating hormone which
in turn can increase the risk of
irregular periods
infertility and poor bone health now
while we don't
have a lot of research on humans yet
because intermittent fasting is kind of
a new hot phenomenon
early tests in rats have shown that just
three to six months of alternate day
fasting reduced ovary size and caused
irregular reproductive cycles
so something to consider if you're
wanting to start a family
and you're dieting heavily which i'm not
suggesting that is the case for shayla
but it may be for a lot of her viewers
who are watching
finally if i were to suggest any
supplements for shayla i would probably
like to see
a omega-3 supplement largely because i
didn't see
really any sources of omega-3 in her
diet
and maybe even vitamin d as well because
she
was probably getting a little bit of
vitamin d in the
coconut milk in day one and day two but
otherwise
likely not meeting her needs okay so
then on to the nitty gritty here
in general is this way of eating
balanced
well in terms of calories at 1885
calories and a goal to lose weight
i would say shayla's caloric deficit
would predict
around a half pound of weight loss per
week which is actually
a pretty sustainable rate so i mean not
bad there
her way of eating well not keto is
relatively low carb and higher fat
which is totally fine if that's working
great for her
having said that i would say she could
optimize her workouts
to keep the fat a little lower around
the workouts and then
spread her carbs and protein out a
little bit more throughout the day to
get
the most out of every gram my bigger
concern is really the lack of fruits and
vegetables in her day which
may prevent her from getting all of the
micronutrients that she actually needs
when i ran the numbers i saw that she
was only getting 19 grams of fiber which
is a little under the 25 gram
recommendation
and she's only getting two-thirds of her
potassium needs
both of these issues could be easily
remedied by
some more vegetables and fruit and like
i said it before
i would definitely love to see some
sources of omega-3s in her diet
but if she's not a fan of fatty fish or
she doesn't want to incorporate
things like you know flax or chia seeds
or
hemp hearts or things like that into her
diet then of course an omega-3
supplement
may be indicated finally in general i
would just love to see
more variety in her meals out of the
three days
there was literally only a total count
of 17
different foods plus condiments like
spices hot sauce and coffee
just 17. i mean meals don't have to be
complicated with a million ingredients
to be healthy
in fact whatever is easy and sustainable
is often best in my books but i would
just
love to see those ingredients kind of
switched up a little bit more
and that would help us optimize overall
nutrition
ultimately i would argue that the level
of meticulous restriction
and repetitiveness of this diet is
unlikely to be sustainable for
anyone long term and i would urge shayla
to try to find ways to make this
an enjoyable lifestyle before her
willpower to eat another ground chicken
wrap
runs dry now are there any problematic
claims or assumptions made by this
channel
well let's just say that if somebody is
sensitive to
diet talk and a lot of diet culture and
weighing
and calorie counting this would not be
a channel i recommend shayla is
obviously extremely driven by
aesthetic weight loss and she achieves
this through really strict diet rules
and rigidity
while i was happy not to see a channel
littered with extreme cheat day
documentation
she does talk about having a cheat day
once a week
to eat the foods that she loves and that
she craves so
this tells me that shayla could enjoy
food
and inherently does enjoy food and would
probably be a lot more enthusiastic
about
meals if she actually allowed herself a
little more variety
than those 17 different ingredients
also you know how i feel about cheat
days i mean
if we allowed ourselves enjoyment and
moderation in our day-to-day diet and
lives
there wouldn't need to be a massive
cheat day
not to mention it's actually really easy
to undo the caloric deficit that you
create for yourself
on a cheat day for example if you
created a 350 calorie deficit six days a
week
meaning you under 8 by 2 100 calories a
week
and then on the seventh day you had a
major cheat day and ate an extra 2 000
calories
the entire deficit that you put yourself
through hell and back for
in a week would be lost and that's not
even
like an always hungry kind of cheat day
situation
that would be a pretty modest cheat
this is why the concept i mean even
outside the moral language used to
describe it
just doesn't make a whole lot of sense
to me in the context of weight loss
another thing i didn't love was her
discussion on how intermittent fasting
will
flatten you out i think any time an
influencer is making claims about a diet
that they're following that has not been
supported by a large body of evidence
for the general public
i just think that they should have a
disclaimer that they're not a health
expert and that this is just their
personal experience
and their beliefs intermittent fasting
may result in weight loss due to the
fact that there is
often a reduction in calories and
insulin levels due to eating
in a smaller eating window but like any
diet
it's just not sustainable for most
people
now finally what can we take away from
shayla's channel that is
positive well first of all i will say
that all of shayla's meals are
definitely
very approachable they're simple to
prepare
they're featuring everyday ingredients i
mean there's nothing
crazy going on here which i definitely
appreciate
seeing also while a lot of shayla's
fitness goals are aesthetic based
to lean up which is fine and totally
fair as i said
she also has some goals that i
definitely want to focus on talking
about
one is that she wants to work towards
not tracking her macros
and also not relying on the scale for
progress updates
so often she also talks about how
everyone's health journey is going to be
different
and to not necessarily strive for
perfection which i love
in another video she talks about being
the best version of yourself
and while i think that there are a ton
of ways to accomplish this
outside of exercise and weight loss her
sentiment of
trying to not be so hard on yourself
throughout whatever journey you on
definitely may resonate bottom line
shayla's diet may not be the most
exciting
varied balanced diet and it would
no doubt feel super restrictive to most
people
if shayla is feeling good and strong
eating this way
and is not triggered by the extreme
measures that she's
had to take then i'm glad that it's
working for her
i don't want to project my own sadness
with this diet when she herself says
she doesn't mind eating the same things
every single day
as she mentions her journey and her diet
has been a lot of trial and error
and she has been trying to just find the
best way to fuel her body
that's totally fair but i would also
encourage shayla to find ways to support
her mind
and her relationship with food as well
of course i would love to see shayla
just like
space her meals out a little bit more
throughout the day up her fruits and
vegetables
and most importantly to increase the
variety
in her meals but i would also just love
to say that
there's no need to wait until she's
reached her goal weight to focus on
having a more supportive
relationship with food that might mean
weighing her food less often tracking
her calories
less aggressively and allowing herself
food that she's
actually excited to eat every single
day not just on cheat days so bottom
line
i think it's important to remember that
wellness is not just about what your
body looks like
or even how it physically operates but
that
you feel content and happy in your
everyday
well folks that is all for today's video
a big thank you again to squarespace for
sponsoring this video
if you liked it be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below with
who you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel
and i'll see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye
you